Angelika hätte man ist stellvertretende
politikchefin der Bild am Sonntag und
sie begrüße ich jetzt in Berlin Frau
Hellemann in Umfragen liegt die AFD ja
in bei einigen Umfragen zumindest bei
knapp 20% und die Union von CDU und CSU
die Suchtmittel dagegen und versucht
auch sich dagegen zu stemmen Wüste der
Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen waren davor dass man
sich dem Sprachgebrauch der
Rechtspopulisten zu eigen macht da
Parteichef März weiss den
Ministerpräsident dann am Sonntag noch
mal zurecht und sagt den Jungs und
Fragen hätte die AFD auch in
Nordrhein-Westfalen kräftig zugelegt ist
das ein neuer Richtung Streit innerhalb
der Union
es ist vor allen Dingen erstmal ein
Streit um die Macht Friedrich Merz hat
mal sehr vollmundig angekündigt dass er
als
cdu-parteichef die afd-werte halbieren
wird das sagt er schon lange nicht mehr
und es ist ihm auch in keinster Weise
gelungen denn von der ampelschwäche
profitiert halt gerade eben nicht die
Union sondern sehr stark die AFD und da
kommt jetzt auch tatsächlich
Enttäuschung auf in der CDU und jetzt
fängt an der Ministerpräsident aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen der halt auch den
mächtigsten Landesverband anführt und
der sozusagen war Amt eigentlich immer
auch ein möglicher Kanzlerkandidat ist
den Friedrich Merz ein bisschen
herauszufordern
damit würde aber ja mit einem
Kanzlerkandidaten Hendrik wüst die CDU
ein Stück weit in die Mitte ziehen macht
man dann nicht noch mehr Platz für die
AFD wie sieht man das im politischen
Berlin
naja also die CDU steht halt tatsächlich
immer noch weiter von einem
Richtungsstreit Friedrich Merz ist
ziemlich klar mit seiner Absage an die
AFD also keinerlei Kooperationen auf
Bundes- oder Landesebene und da ist er
auch ziemlich glasklar und glaubwürdig
aber Merkel hat eben eine ziemlich
verunsicherte Partei zurückgelassen die
auch ziemlich gespalten ist also gerade
im Osten wird ihr Kurs mittlerweile sehr
sehr kritisch gesehen auch ihre
Flüchtlingspolitik sorgt immer noch für
Verheerungen in der Partei und ja
Friedrich Merz war ja immer ein
erklärter Gegner von Merkel und wüst
benutzt jetzt die ehemalige Kanzlerin
ein bisschen auch um sich zu
positionieren zum Beispiel hat er dann
Angela Merkel den Verdienstorden seines
Landes gegeben und sie damit
ausgezeichnet bei der Verleihung war
natürlich wer nicht dabei Friedrich Merz
Friedrich Merz hat auch als sie den das
Bundesverdienstkreuz von Frank-Walter
Steinmeier bekommen hat sich ja
offensichtlich hat sich seine Zunge
verknotet zumindest konnte er ihr nicht
gratulieren und auch bei der Feier war
nicht anwesend das sind schon eigentlich
ziemlich deutlicher Zeichen und anhand
diese Streites sucht die CDU immer noch
ihre Linie und eben auch die Macht und
wer sich eben wirklich an die Spitze
stellt und Friedrich Merz hat
tatsächlich im Moment gerade mit
Beschuss aus eigenen Reihen zu kämpfen
ja wenn sich zwei streiten freut sich ja
bekanntlich der dritte und der dritte
der sitzt aber nicht in der CDU sondern
in der CSU und in Bayern das ist nämlich
Markus Söder der bayerische
Ministerpräsident hat jetzt noch eine
Wahl im Herbst zu bestehen welche
Chancen räumen Sie den denn ein dass er
vielleicht dann doch noch mal ins Rennen
um die Kanzlerkandidatur gehen könnte
also Markus Söder sagte im Moment immer
Bayern Bayern und mein Platz ist in
Bayern aber so wirklich glaubt dem hier
keiner also wenn Markus Söder ein gutes
Wahlergebnis hinlegt und das wäre
übrigens sein erstes weil alle Wahlen
vorher da hat er immer große
Minuszeichen eingefahren oder eben auch
bei den Bundestagswahlen unter ihm als
CSU-Chef dann wird er das als Kraftschub
nehmen und dann wird er mitmischen da
wird er gar nicht anders können und dann
wird es halt wieder noch mal einen
zusätzlichen Machtkampf zwischen CDU und
CSU geben weil die CDU hat halt Markus
Söder dann doch nicht vergessen was er
im letzten Bundestagswahlkampf
angerichtet hat eben mit diesem
wahnsinnigen macht Kampf mit Armin
Laschet und danach eben mit der ja im
Grunde genommen auch komplett die
Montage des eigenen Kanzlerkandidaten
wie sehen Sie denn da einen Ausweg aus
dem Dilemma weil eigentlich hat die UN
Ion ja immer noch nicht entschieden wie
man sich ja auch einen künftigen
Kanzlerkandidaten einigen will beim
letzten Mal hatten sie gerade eben uns
das noch mal gut erklärt was ein riesen
Dilemma aber wie will man denn jetzt bei
der nächsten Wahl damit umgehen und
eigentlich muss man sich ja schon mal
demnächst klar werden wer denn ins
Rennen gehen soll
das ist sehr schwierig sie haben halt
kein ja kein wirkliches Prozedere es
wird glaube ich nicht so ausgehen dass
ich Friedrich Merz und Markus Söder
zusammen irgendwo in Berlin oder in
München in einem Zimmer einschließen
können oder ein Frühstück irgendwo in
der Bundesrepublik veranstalten wie
damals zwischen Stoiber und Merkel
sondern die Landesfürsten also einmal
eben wüst als auch Daniel Günther im
Norden die wollen einen gehöriges Wort
mitreden und dann kommt es halt drauf an
wer so seine Truppen hat März hat ja
neulich schon mal einen Testballon
gestartet da haben zwei seiner engsten
Vertrauten ihn ausgerufen und schon mal
gesagt also es ist doch ganz klar dass
der Friedrich Merz unser Kanzlerkandidat
wird so richtig Applaus gehabt da aber
nicht und es ist auch ja keiner so
richtig gefolgt und das zeigt einfach
gerade hat noch
wirklich die Truppen hinter sich und ist
wirklich durchsetzungsstark und dann
muss man auch erstmal noch mal gucken
wie so die weiteren Landtagswahlen
ablaufen wenn jetzt zum Beispiel im
Herbst wird ja nicht nur in Bayern
gewählt sondern auch in Hessen wenn dort
die CDU noch mal ein sehr gutes Ergebnis
einfährt dann würde das tatsächlich auch
immer den Bundesvorsitzenden stärken
wird das Ergebnis nicht gut schlecht es
ihnen natürlich also drei Männer in der
Union um Kampf um die Macht das waren
Einschätzung von Angelika Herrmann von
der Bild am Sonntag ganz herzlichen Dank
gerne